the jurogan experience have you known
anybody that got bit by a shark
yes
how many guys one of my friends got bit
by a shark less than a week ago oh yeah
how is it he was almost positive as a
great white shark oh jesus
and how's this it was in hawaii really
it was at my home break that's crazy
banyan's in kona on the big island isn't
that rare they had been seeing a great
white for three weeks in that area
a lot of like the
a lot of like they have like manta ray
boats and dolphin boats and like whale
whale watching boats go out and i'm
buddies with some of these guys and
they've been seeing a great white
they've been filming it on the surface
this big big like a 12 great white and
this guy
his name is jared williford and he was
he he's a crazy fisherman he catches
like full-sized massive uh blue marlin
off the coast of kona and his kayak
he's like a dude with the dreads he's
like real stoney bologna what does he
catch him off a kayak he catches him
with his fishing pole kayak like he's on
a boat but he just goes his kayak and
he'll get um he'll he'll he'll hook up
with a marlin or a big tuna and it'll
pull him miles out to sea on his kayak
i've had multiple friends who fish for a
living are like dude i saw jared with a
marlin
on his kayak
i'm dead serious he's crazy anyway
so he had a run-in with a great white
like a couple weeks before and he was
like he was like he
he um he was like telling guys at the
beach i had to run in with the great
white when i was on my kayak and
everyone you know just figured he was
full of [ __ ] like there's no way and
then next you know and it's on on the i
should pull up on my phone but it's so
there's webcams at a lot of these surf
breaks now and at my home break at
banyan's there's a webcam now it's a
surf line webcam so
24 hours a day there's a camera and so
his attack is on camera
yeah
yeah this is it whoa video of surfer
being attacked and dragged underwater by
shark at banyan's on hawaii's big island
wham nails him right there he's down now
he's gonna pop up and swim to that guy
yeah so there's a video this is the
video right here i'll play this
sweet baby jesus this is where i grew up
surfing i don't know where's the video
there it is i'll click on that
so this is my home break
i've been surfing this since i was five
years old that's that now right after
this wave you'll see it comes at wham
nails it right he's under water he's
down
now he's gonna pop up
right
there
and swim to that guy
whoa so that was a girl next to him
whoa a girl was paddling out next to him
shark comes up grabs him takes him
underwater
and he comes up
and hangs onto that girl's surfboard his
board's gone
oh my god
you can see the size of the shark's huge
too you don't see it much you don't no
you see the fin though come up oh
so it grabbed the board and him and how
badly did he get bit
it it shredded his forearm pretty much
completely
oh my god and so and so my wife was just
just the other day my wife uh my wife
was talking to the girl who was there in
that video who was next to him so shark
comes up just nails him takes him
underwater and she's just sitting there
like holy [ __ ] this guy's toast he's
dead for sure and she was thinking she
was dead too and then all of a sudden he
pops up right next to her
and the shark's still right there and
she said it was moving like crazy slow
like a big slow submarine
you know how scary that is and it's
shallow there it's like four feet deep
where they were this massive tank of a
shark is in four feet of water and just
sucked them under and his it shredded
his arm it didn't suck him under dude he
grabbed him with his freaking jaws and
pulled him under and did he get his arm
fixed like yeah so he is still in the
icu are you still in the hospital
wow still
and so i haven't talked to him
personally but um it shredded his arm
like horribly bad i think he might have
lost function in some of his fingers and
anyway this this girl who was right next
to him so his board was gone and he was
gushing blood like crazy like
hemorrhaging blood and so she was on top
of her board paddling he
swam under her board and held onto her
board and she tried to paddle him to the
beach she took off her leash
which is like you know your leads to
your board accord and and wrapped it
super tightly around his arm as a
tourniquet
and sit and
fully saved his life and then when he
was on the way in and another guy swam
out and did another tourniquet on his
arm
and saved his life but i guess he lost
tons and tons of blood
guys lucky yeah
extremely lucky unlucky and lucky at the
same time it could have been could have
been so much worse have you ever had an
encounter i have i've had encounters
i've seen seen a bunch of sharks and
seen some big sharks
what a wild creature right just to clean
up crew of the ocean they're terrifying
the heavy thing is like if you have a
run-in with a great white shark
there's a really good chance that
they're not going to eat you right they
chill a lot of times but if they're
hungry if they haven't eaten in a i
don't know how how often do great whites
eat jamie
let's guess
i say they have to eat once a week yeah
i'd say four days maybe
let's see
it says it says the amount of energy
required by great white sharks was
equivalent to eating a seal pup every
three days
oh yeah so
so if you run into a like a white shark
and it sees you it's not going to eat
unless it's really hungry but if it's
starving you're toast that's it bad luck
yeah i mean they eat shoes sometimes
they eat all kinds of things yeah
especially like by my house there's a
lot of tiger sharks and tiger sharks are
like they bite first ask questions later
like they like they'll like they'll fish
out a tiger shark and and and cut his
stomach open there's like license plates
and shoes and [ __ ] like a lot of stuff
so they're more aggressive yeah they're
more aggressive they'll just bite
anything they need six according to this
research uh they need about 66 pounds of
blubber to survive for no more than 15
days
wow so i'm trying to do the math of my
head for two weeks has a lot 30 pounds a
week
so if he's really hungry he might just
eat you but even if he just bites you
you're probably dead
yeah your your guy got lucky yeah my
friend was incredibly lucky